Harry are you surprised by the ruling
I'm not and I think I'm course you're
gonna say that 500 yeah she read all our
research we've been all over it but you
know I think that the TV stocks you know
some of the TV stocks that Alex
mentioned like Sinclair at the end
they're down 20 they were down twenty to
thirty percent just this year primarily
on this aerial concern so it was a
really big concern for investors we're
seeing it pop at the stocks pop back
here but there was a lot of uncertainty
here because retransmission fees have
really become the lifeblood if you will
of the TV business I mean it used to be
just they had to depend upon advertising
now they actually have a second revenue
stream where they're getting paid by the
cable companies that's really been a
lifeblood for the sector it's driven M&A
in 2013 so it's been a really big issue
long term clearly the stocks are
reacting but what does this mean
long-term does this mean that the
because Aereo isn't going to be the
first and probably won't be the last
company to try and disrupt a
broadcasting model do you believe that
we haven't read the ruling yet but just
in principle does it insulate
broadcasting from a tax like area yeah
what I think this ruling does and again
it seemed at six to three as you
mentioned it's fairly sweeping I think
the issue is it just reaffirms the value
of a copyright of the local broadcast
and at the end of the day that is the
primary asset of a local broadcast
station the vet you know the value of
their signal and their ability to get
paid either through advertising or
through retransmission fees so I think
this ruling just once and for all just
kind of validated the copyright value
Eric use that time with Barry Diller
what was it two months ago hmm what did
he say to you what was he if this resume
he said it was life and death he said it
was life and death so this is death this
is death and the CEO vario said
basically there is no plan B here so you
know there really is no other business
model here and I think you know what
Barry Diller it was trying to do here
was to simply thread a very very narrow
loophole that he thought he saw in the
copyright law and clearly the Supreme
Court said no you're very Diller it's
not an expensive trade no you know he
likes that you know this is typical back
Barry Diller he likes it to disrupt
everything whether it's broadcast
television 25 years ago with the fox
network or whether it's with home
shopping or any of those types of things
so this was just another example of
Barry Diller saying you know he thought
it could be disrupted maybe you know
shake up the world a little bit in terms
of
casting let's actually bring that in
Eric as we said spoke to him just two
months ago I mean for Barry why not take
a long shot he's got a lot of dough take
a look it's very possible that there's
some Salvage but area would probably as
I say probably just because I can't I
can't see any path for it probably would
not be able to continue in business